bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france 24 notre invité aujourd'hui
et le président du ghana nana akufo addo
merci beaucoup d'être avec nicky merci
de nous recevoir à nouveau
vous présidez également la communauté
économique des états d'afrique de
l'ouest
la france et l'europe ont annoncé qu'ils
allaient se retirer militairement du
mali est-ce que cela crée un vide sur le
plan de la sécurité pour le mali le
sahel et pour des pays comme le vôtre
clairement nous avons besoin de trouver
un nouvel accord de sécurité à la
lumière de la décision des pays
européens suivant l'exemple de la france
de quitter le théâtre des opérations au
mali
nous avons entamé des discussions afin
de voir
quelles modifications doivent être
apportées à la position de la cedeao en
termes de sécurité ainsi que celle à des
forces européennes car mon
interprétation de la déclaration du
président français fait en privé et en
public et que les forces vont être
redéployés au niger essentiellement
ceux ci aura donc un impact sur la
posture générale et la stratégie des
différentes parties prenantes
aïeux est ce que vous regrettez cette
décision je ne peut la regretter il
s'agit d'une décision prise par la
france la décision initiale de venir au
mali avaient été prises entre le
gouvernement français et malien de
l'époque c'était une décision qui a été
prise
la situation les conditions au mali font
qu'il est difficile pour les forces
françaises de rester nous devons définir
un nouveau cadre tout simplement
d'accord l'une des raisons invoquées et
l'arrivée de mercenaires russes le
groupe wagner le président français a
affirmé qu'ils étaient près de 800
est-ce que c'est aussi une ligne rouge
pour vous je ne suis pas convaincu que
ce soit la raison je pense plutôt que
c'est le manque de coopération entre les
forces françaises et le gouvernement
malien qui a motivé cette décision je je
suis pas sûr que ce soit la présence de
ces mercenaires étrangers qui les ai
poussés à partir je ne comprends pas est
ce que c'est une source de préoccupation
pour vous monsieur le président tout le
monde est préoccupé nous avons depuis
longtemps un protocole bien établi au
sein de la cedeao et de l'ua contre
l'intervention de mercenaires étrangers
dans les affaires intérieures de nos
états et donc si des mercenaires
viennent perturber la vie des habitants
au mali cela nous préoccupe si vous
connaissez l'histoire de notre continent
et ce dont je ne doute pas vous
connaissez le rôle que les mercenaires
étrangers ont joué dans notre histoire
et ce n'était pas positif
donc ils doivent partir bien sûr nous
préférerions gérer cela avec l'état et
le gouvernement malien
le fait de traiter avec l'état le
gouvernement malien c'était un problème
pour la cedeao vous avez été très
impliqué et un des principaux points
d'achoppement c'est le calendrier des
élections il a une nouvelle proposition
de l'algérie concernant une période de
transition de 16 mois la junte a affirmé
qu'il lui fallait quatre ans
y at il une solution réaliste à
l'horizon nous verrons dans ces affaires
la table des négociations est toujours
ouverte mais est ce que ces négociations
se poursuivent
il ya des contacts et des dialogues en
cours mais le plus important en ce qui
nous concerne c'est qu'il y avait un
accord accroissent entre la cedeao et le
gouvernement de transition au début de
l'année 2020
un accord de clore le processus de
transition en février de cette année à
la fin de ce mois
à la dernière minute la nouvelle junte
au mali nous a informé qu'elle n'était
plus en position de respecter cet
engagement et qu'elle
propose et qu'elle comptait rester au
pouvoir pendant quatre ou cinq ans nous
avons été très surpris et choqué je suis
le président élu du ghana et j'ai un
mandat de quatre ans et le fait qu un
régime non élu et illégitime souhaite
rester au pouvoir avec la malle de la
cedeao pendant quatre à cinq ans nous
semblait tout simplement scandaleux
c'est pourquoi cette proposition a été
rejetée
nous sommes déterminés à travailler sur
une solution plus acceptable et qu'elle
serait de solution plus acceptable 12
mois 18 mois nous verrons cela dépendra
de ce qui est proposé mais clairement en
l'état actuel des choses la proposition
des autorités maliennes est tout
simplement inacceptable
moins d'un an est ce que cela serait
acceptable
personnellement après m'être entretenu
avec la maison homologue je pense qu'une
période de 12 mois serait acceptable
mais il s'agit là de mon avis ce n'est
pas la politique de la cedeao tu nous
devons réfléchir ensemble nous asseoir
autour d'une table et voir ce qui est
faisable
évidemment il ya aussi le burkina faso
la cedeao il ya envoyé une délégation il
semble être plus optimiste
s'agissant des intentions de la junte là
bas est ce que vous êtes également plus
optimiste sur le fait que le scénario du
mali ne se reproduira pas là bas pour le
moment les signaux et les déclarations
qui viennent de ouagadougou sous la
nouvelle autorité militaire
sont plus encourageants
des moves nous verrons jusqu'où cela va
mais ils sont allés très vite ils ont
mis en place un comité technique de leur
côté pour faire des propositions à la
junte sur un calendrier de transition
et nous avons l'impression qu'ils sont
pressé pressé de mettre en place un
cadre de transition acceptable
dix-huit mois comme ce qui avait été
prévu initialement pour le mali est ce
que c'est réaliste ou es ce que vous
avez peur que nous verrons ce qu'il
advient
en définitive notre position est très
simple
il appartient aux autorités militaires
de trouver un accord avec la cedeao est
un programme qui soit acceptable pour la
cedeao
voilà la position que nous allons
maintenir pendant 6 mois 9 mois 12 mois
peu importe
mais pas plus
oui
nous ne souhaitons pas que l'afrique de
l'ouest retombe à l'époque du règne
militaire nous souhaitons nous en
éloigner
oui mais vous êtes en train d'y retomber
et prenons la guinée environ six mois
après le coup d'état le colonel
doumbouya n'a donné aucun calendrier est
ce que vous êtes inquiet parce que
l'horloge tourne bien sûr nous sommes
inquiets nous l'avons dit toutes nos
déclarations publiques ont indiqué
davantage de sanctions à l'horizon
nous verrons nous avons fait part de nos
inquiétudes quant à l'absence d'un
calendrier clair pour la restauration
d'un régime démocratique en guinée les
camps devrait-il fournir ce calendrier à
tout moment dès que possible
l'engagement la communication est
constante minwin
nous avons été témoins d'une épidémie
coups d'état en afrique de l'ouest cela
doit vous préoccuper car ces coups
d'état sont assez populaire
non je ne comprends pas non il n'y a
qu'une poignée de personnes dans la
région de la capitale il y en a plus
qu'une poignée monsieur le président je
ne sais pas les informations que nous
recevons ils ont voit là pourquoi il est
préférable d'avoir un système où un
gouvernement où la popularité se vérifie
facilement par les urnes mais ce que
vous êtes inquiet parce que les états
sont devenus la norme récemment annonce
n'est pas la norme une tendance alors je
ne sais pas si on peut vraiment parler
d'une tendance
cela s'est produit dans trois états sur
les 15 membres de la cedeao pour le
moment alors évidemment nous ne
souhaitons pas que cette contagion se
propage et nous allons nous assurer que
cela ne se produira pas nous travaillons
au niveau national pour offrir une bonne
gouvernance à nos citoyens pour qu'il
n'y ait aucune base aucun prétexte pour
une intervention
et en parallèle nous allons insister sur
le respect de nos propres protocoles
nous avons des protocole contraignant en
matière de bonne gouvernance et de
démocratie dans la région nous sommes
déterminés à travailler en ce sens est
ce un danger mortel pour la région
je ne comprends pas le concept de danger
mortel lorsque l'on parle des tas de
communauté et de fonctions d'état
il y à toute sorte d'évolution mais
celle ci n'est certainement pas la
bienvenue et nous allons nous assurer
qu'elles ne se répètent pas et si
possible d'avoir même un retour à la
normale
le nigeria a affirmé que la question du
nombre de mandats limités par exemple
l'idée du troisième mandat représentait
d'un problème est qu'il était à
l'origine de ce type de coup d'état on
l'a vu en guinée le troisième mandat
d'alpha condé est la raison qui explique
le coup d'état est ce que vous êtes
préoccupé
je ne suis pas sûr que le colonel
doumbia et disent ah non il n'a pas dit
ça ce sont des spéculations pour
colporter par des personnes comme vous
mais ce que la cedeao devrait être la
cedeao est préoccupé nous l'avons déjà
indiqué au monde nous avons dit que nous
étions dans un processus de révision que
nous nous pensions sur nos protocoles de
base à la lumière de l'évolution de la
situation et je pense que c'est une
source de préoccupation moi par exemple
je suis préoccupé par cette affaire
heureusement pour moi le sujet est
clairement déterminée par la pratique et
les principes c'est à dire au ghana il y
a deux mandats si on a de la chance
demandez et vous avez de la chance oui
oui
oui je pense d'ailleurs que c'est un bon
modèle pour le reste des états d'afrique
en guise de conclusion est ce que vous
êtes préoccupé par le fait que des coups
d'état pourrait toucher le ghana qui
pourraient être déstabilisés ou est-ce
que vous pensez que le solide et robuste
sur le plan de la sécurité de la
démocratie que nous avons vu ce qui
s'est passé aux états unis le 6 janvier
et il ya eu une tentative
les états unis avaient deux cents ans de
gouvernement démocratique sans
interruption mais il ya eu une tentative
d'insurrection
et donc le sujet de la stabilité dans
tout etat est un sujet permanent c'est
pourquoi on connaît l'adage le prix de
la liberté et la vigilance éternel c'est
à dire que toujours à chaque génération
il faut surveiller la stabilité la
cohérence des institutions politiques et
étatiques et il faut s'assurer que ces
institutions suivent l'époque et
j'espère que c'est ce qui se passe au
canada c'est le président merci beaucoup
de nous avoir accordé de votre temps
vous êtes très occupé à bruxelles pour
le sommet eut e union africaine et merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cet entretien sur
france 24
[Musique]